like okay who would you build a business
around would you build a business around
a great ceo or your top performer like
what's who if you haven't first of all
i asked this question from uh uh i asked
this question from uh who's the great
player of new york uh old school anyways
he's uh
i cannot forget no in new york city he
played for nick's back in the day seven
years ago
no one at that era though he played with
phil jackson
yes and i said what's the most important
thing to build around is it ownership
i've asked this question a few times
from owners players all these guys
ownership a rock star player a head
coach
a gm who's the most super star get me a
super guess what he said he said
ownership is number one no doubt he said
ownership is number one
then superstar
then head coach then gm yeah it was so
interesting the way he put it he says
because if like imagine if donald
sterling has michael jordan do you think
the clippers are going to go be the next
chicago bulls hell no no no it's not
going to do nothing like that right so
you need an owner at the top like a
craft you know you people don't give
enough credibility to guys like
steinberg or like jerry buss 33 years of
owning the lakers the guy won 10
championships one out of three years the
lakers won it so
that's the argument but superstar after
you have a great owner listen your
bradys don't come along all the time
yeah but you got to hold your breath
they don't get hurt it's not even close
all right listen
in the entertainment industry
specifically you can have an
unbelievable writer incredible cast all
right but if the director doesn't know
what he's doing the executive producer
doesn't know how to promote the film or
doesn't know how the movie's gonna be
terrible how many times have you seen an
amazing look at batman with val kilmer
george clooney incredible actors massive
casts all the money in the world thrown
at this thing and then you get you know
bad suits with nipples you know what i'm
saying like that's some people like that
the joel schumacher batman nobody in the
world is going to say val kilmer is a
bad actor right val kilmer is a massive
incredible actor doc hollywood great
security guard though
he's great no no no that's uh londran
right
with the chasse
i mean so you got doc holliday and you
got you know one of the great character
actors of all time he becomes batman
it's a terrible movie it's always it's
top down guys you could the the best
leadership guys can create an
environment for people to be successful
people to perform that's that's what i
think i think look you could be an
unbelievable salesman but if if you
can't have a team around you that's
going to be able to support by the way
it's not even close 90 of people say
they would choose brady over belgium
they would choose
brady over belichick yeah
yeah as a player
yeah i don't think bill belichick should
be lining up across
tom brady let's see what happens let's
see what happens by the way what about
that kick this week 66 yards 66 insane
you notice how we have we haven't seen
paul garcia all week he's a huge lions
fan he's like on suicide walks right now
[Music]
by the way can you call that the
greatest field goal winnings you know
regular season
you know all the time
i'm not going to put a
i think so for sure shout out to your
new creative director fellow ut alum
with uh zp zp is a ut hook um who is zp
by the way who is who is zp that's by
the way that's our new line who is
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you